et on va parler de la situation en
Russie avec notre invité Elsa Vidal
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
la chef du service russe de RFI Radio
France Internationale on le voyait en
les sanctions se multiplient contre la
Russie plusieurs entreprises
internationales ont suspendu leur
activité dans le pays et la plus
arbatique peut-être cette semaine c'est
McDonald's les McDonald's qui ferment
leur porte partout en Russie on a
l'impression finalement de revenir en
URSS quand McDo n'était pas présent dans
le pays est-ce que vous avez des échos
de la situation sur place est-ce que les
Russes sont inquiets devant toutes ces
fermetures oui oui on a de nombreux
échos qui nous arrivent par des canaux
tant professionnels que personnel parce
que nombre d'entre nous sommes liés
depuis de nombreuses décennies
maintenant avec la société russe et le
choc était énorme les gens ont d'abord
été sidérés et aujourd'hui ils regardent
leur pays se retient se retirer du monde
et un rideau de fer se réinstaller qui
va les couper d'un mode de vie qu'ils
avaient commencé à mais comme le leur il
y a ces jeunes informés qui ne
soutiennent pas à la politique du
Kremlin mais il y a toutes ces personnes
biberonnées j'ai envie de dire aux
chaînes de télévision d'État eux
soutiennent Poutine on voit qu'il y a
vraiment une fracture dans la société
russe aujourd'hui il y a une division
croissante qui est marquée entre les
personnes qui s'informent par les
chaînes de télévision qui restent une
très grande majorité à peu près 80% de
la population et ceux qui ont accès aux
médias alternatifs à l'Internet au VPN
et bien sûr ça recouvre une fracture
générationnelle assez simple à lire et
tous les récents sondages auxquels on a
eu accès qui ont été réalisés tant par
des instituts proches des autorités que
par des instituts considérés plus proche
de l'opposition d'un à entendre que à
peu près 75% de la population russe
soutient ce qui se passe actuellement en
Ukraine il faut quand même souligner que
la question est libellée d'une manière
toujours très particulière et qui ne
leur est pas demandé s'il soutiennent la
guerre mais est-ce qu'ils soutiennent
l'opération spéciale qui est en train de
se passer en Ukraine ce qui est un
billet très important alors justement on
va le rappeler pour noter les
spectateurs le mot guerre et proscrit de
tous les médias russes en ce moment les
chaînes d'État ne parle donc
d'opérations spéciales ou d'opération
humanitaire mais il y a quand même des
médias qui continuent qui essayent de
continuer leur travail via des des
chaînes télégrammes ou via leur leur
site internet mais en bannissant ce mot
ce mot guerre pour lequel ils sont
passifs de 15 ans de prison quand même
oui effectivement la mobilisation
finalement de la société russe quand
bien même elle n'entraîne pas
immédiatement un changement de régime et
même si elle nous semble limité elle
fait suffisamment peur aux autorités
pour avoir entraîné l'adoption d'une loi
qu'on appelle la loi sur les fausses
nouvelles mais qui en réalité est
presque l'introduction d'une loi
martiale puisqu'elle rétablit une
censure très stricte qui interdit non
seulement la couverture par les médias
des opérations militaire qui se passe en
Ukraine en utilisant d'autres termes que
celui des autorités donc il est interdit
de parler de guerre mais il est aussi
interdit pour les personnes
individuelles pour n'importe quelle
russe d'appeler à une opposition
d'appeler à des sanctions et si les
autorités considèrent qu'un citoyen
s'est rendu coupable à de multiples
reprises les peines de prison et les
amendes peuvent être astronomiques et
atteintes jusqu'à 15 ans alors on le
voyait derrière vous des des images de
manifestations il y a il y a quelques
instants manifester c'est devenu
dangereux également en Russie el-zavidal
on sent que ça c'est en fait radicalisé
que les gens qui vont manifester vont
manifester en général depuis plusieurs
années ils le font en toute connaissance
de cause ce qu'on n'avait jamais vu
jusque là c'était dans des quatre é
restreints c'était l'interdiction aux
avocats d'accéder aux clients c'était
les avocats brutalisés et c'était des
enfants qui ont passé parfois la nuit
avec leurs parents dans des cellules
disons de garde à vue et ça c'est
nouveau